Alhamdulillah. Continuing
[Silence]
the 210th chapter, the chapter of the
virtues and merits of the day of Jum.
The first merit mentioned by in this
chapter is the merit with respect to the
day of J being chosen by Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala as the day to start great
events
with respect to
our existence here in this dunya.
Our
[Silence]
messenger
was said that the best day upon which
the sun has ever risen is the day of
Jum. On that day, Adam was created and
on that day he was admitted into
paradise and on that day he was taken
out of paradise. And this becomes
virtuous because these three
events
are
some of the most significant events for
for humanity. And on that day Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala created Adam.
And so the human being came to be. On
that day he admitted him into paradise.
And so that is the time when How was
created. And on that day he was taken
out of paradise. And that is the day
when all of us began. So the fact that
Allah chose that day specifically for
all of these events.
In another narration in Muslim, the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam added
and the day and the day of reckoning,
the day of judgment will commence on the
day of J as well. that final that first
blow into the horn by Israel
that will be on the day of J.
And so Abu
what is his name?
Abu Hurra's name quick guyshd
Iben.
no that's no
Abu is Abdman
and he is from where? Di
is Abu and he accepted Islam. Which
year?
Which year?
Yes. More importantly, the battle of
No,
no, Han was way later. Okay. Oh, it was
way before we you either jump in the
shark or jumping before the shark. It
was the day of what' you say.
No, that was Salman and Pharisees first.
See why we review
And he passed away which year?
59. after.
[Silence]
Muslim on the authority of
who narrates that the messenger of
Allah.
said, "Whoever makes wudoo and perfects
his wudoo and then comes to J and
listens and is silent,
he is going to be pardoned of his sins,
those sins which were between that and
the
previous Jum with an addition of
three days. And whoever plays with the
stones on the ground or fiddles
then this person has fallen into
which is breaking of his silence. This
will invalidate a person's reward. This
reward specifically this has been corre
reported by im Muslim. So he says,
"Whoever makes
what is
in the Arabic language is
excellence." Yeah. In Arabic it is what?
So he's saying whoever makes and then
perfects his woo. How do we perfect our
wudoo? The prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam has many narrations of his
companions narrating how he used to make
wudoo. And so this is not a mystery. We
know exactly how he made wudoo. We know
exactly what he did, what he didn't do.
And hence there are many narrations.
Some narrations which are above
reproach. There are some narrations
which are very strong and authentic,
some narrations which are acceptable,
some narrations which are slightly weak,
some narrations that are very weak. But
when we gather all of those narrations,
we see that the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam his woo was most
comprehensively
narrated
by
Now this is why many of the major books
such as alkari and Muslim they use the
narration of arman as the anchor
narration the base narration for the
description of the prophet's wudoo and
then the other narrations from the other
companions if they add something that's
not specifically mentioned in the
narration of
told his
servant to bring him water and so he
described
by way of acting out the prophet
sallall.aii
Wasallam's woo. His most complete wudoo
and most perfect wudoo was as follows.
He would begin by pouring the water out
onto his hand. If you imagine with me
that the water is in a a pitcher,
right? He wouldn't start by putting his
hand into the water. No, he would pour
the water first into his hand. Wash and
then take from the picture. He would
wash his hands to the wrist three times.
Right? And then he would take with his
right hand
into his mouth and then half into his
nose with one scoop. So he would take
one scoop, he would suck half into his
mouth, half into his nose. He would
inhale the water lightly but as far back
as he could in his nostrils
without it causing him any discomfort or
pain. The prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said that if you make
He said, "If you are making wudoo, then
take in the water into your nostrils as
far as you can unless you are fasting.
If you are fasting, then do not take it
as far as you can so that none of it
goes back into the back of your throat.
Just lightly. Otherwise, if you're not
fasting, you take it in as deeply as you
can. And so, he would take the water,
half in the mouth, half in the nose, and
then he would blow with the left hand
his nose. And the water he would do what
is called ma. Remember we mentioned that
in the Arabic language when there is
repetition of a part of a word or
repetition of of letters that this
articulates what in the Arabic language
zela
ma huh that sound
repetition movement movement and
repetition right that's what it it
articulates and so m
means that he would move the water
around in his mouth. He would move the
water around in his mouth. He would
swish the water around in his mouth and
then he would spit it out. Okay. So,
one, two,
three. Okay. A lot of people when they
make wool, they separate the mouth and
the nose. So they do the mouth three
times, they do the nose three times. The
prophet never did this sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. Is it acceptable? Sure. You've
technically done what you have to.
However, it is not it is not necessarily
a sunnah. It's valid, but it's not the
sunnah. The sunnah is that he would
always do the mouth and the nose
together. Then he would take the water
and wash his face. And the face is from
the hairline
to the ears
to below the chin. This is the
parameters of the face.
He had a very long and thick beard.
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam was described
to have filled his chest, right? Was
this. And so when he would wash his
face, he would wash his face this
just as you're seeing
right three times. Wash his face all of
this. And
once
he would wet his hand, his his left hand
and put his fingers in his beard just
this.
That's it. That is what's called
He didn't do this. He didn't pour water
inside of his beard. No, he would wash
his face and on occasion, not every
time, he would wet his hand and put it
in his beard this, just once. That
is how he did his beard. Sallallah.aii
wasallam. Did he have to wash all of his
beard all the way down? No. The face is
here. Right. And then he would do the
right hand.
Now
woo has to be in order. It can't be done
out of order.
Starting by washing the hands. This is
not a pillar of wudoo.
Your woo technically starts with its
pillars with the face and the mouth and
nose. Washing the hands is an addition
of cleanliness. He didn't always do
that. Sometimes he would just start with
his face and and skip that. And so that
is something which is fine to do. It's
preferred. It's most complete type of
udul.
However, when we're doing the we're
doing in the order of the what is the
order of the
[Silence]
Okay. He says wash your your faces. The
mouth and nose are part of the face. And
wash your hands and arms to include
the elbows. Okay. So, he would take a
scoop, make the water go down, and he
would
wash from the tips of the fingers to
above the elbow to include the elbow.
He would do this three times and the
left three times the tips of the fingers
all the way to include the elbow. And
sometimes he was narrated to have poured
the water onto his elbows to make sure
that he gets above the elbow sai.
Then he would
wet his hands. Okay. And he would
wipe over his head.
Wipe over his head.
This is the wipe that he would do all
the way to the back. Just that one
time.
Sometimes he would wipe and then go back
forward. In the narration of Armen, he
would wipe this
and then go back forward
one time.
However, what is necessary, what is the
least amount and the most common of his
wool, he would wipe once that. That
is it. Just one time.
And
without taking new water, he would
insert his index fingers into his ears
and he would wipe all of the outside of
the ear and the backs of his ears with
his thumbs.
So the front and the back of the ear has
all been wiped entirely just the
head.
The prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam said the ears are part of the
head. Right? So Allah says
this is to include what? The ears
and then he would wash his right foot
to include his ankles. So he'd begin
with the wa right foot. Three times he
would pour the water on his foot and
wash the entire foot to above the ankle
just he did with the elbows. And he
would use his left pinky to go between
the toes
once, not each time. And then the left
foot to include.
And after that he is done with woo that
is the perfected wudoo three times each
except for the head and ears.
Sometimes he would do two times each.
Sometimes he would do one time each and
sometimes he would do some parts two
times and other parts three times. All
of those are in Bkari Muslim. Which one
is the sunnah? All of them. It is the
sunnah to do all of them on occasion,
right?
there's other things people do that
are either inauthentic
narration wise or they have no
narration.
So for instance, wiping the nape of the
neck, right? Wiping the neck. There's no
narration. There's one narration
mentioning that and it is a fabricated
narration. It is one mold.
there's other things people do like
sticking their finger in their
mouth to scrub their teeth when
they're doing mult prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam never did this. None of
his companions did it. It's mentioned by
Enisin Malik
and a rather obscure
narration
that he would do it. But the sunnah is
to use either a toothbrush or siwak
before
making otherwise scrubbing the teeth
with the finger is not something that
the prophet would regularly do.
Sallallam.
So the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam tells us
whoever makes wudoo and perfects his
wudoo perfects this wudoo here then
comes to the etc. This is the wudoo
he was speaking about. You wanted to say
something?
Absolutely. But we'll get to that next
week.
The bare minimum for Jum to be to be
valid is
right. So that's what's mentioned in
this narration.
But other narrations mention and
perfume and all of these other things.
We'll get to them inshallah. But this is
the bare minimum of the day of jum
what a person is to do for J and this
will do is for any salah this is how he
would perform it next week when we
mention the
of we'll mention how he used to make
however how does this narration
harmonize with the narration of
bathing is because when you bathe in the
way that the prophet did. This is the
woo that you will perform when you are
bathing. So they are one and the same.
We'll mention that next week inshallah.